alright sorry for the delays my name is
Matthew Nesbitt i'm the president and
co-founder of coastal genomics my
company has teamed up with hamilton
robotics to pour our Ranger technology
to the Nimbus platform range of
technology allows for the
electrophoresis of DNA for the purposes
of size elections but also for the
purposes of generating analytical
distribution profiles of DNA samples
this presentation will go into a little
bit more about what the new Nimbus
select is capable of and we will also
talk about some of the results that are
generated and realized through use of
this technology
so the first thing that we'd like to
talk about is what are the current
protocol for actually conducting
high-throughput at fragment length
distribution assessments as well as by
selection largely what are used in lab
today for generating electric bureau
grams for DNA examples our computer
systems and these are very usable
solutions that are then comma latent and
commonly adopted however there are some
limitations one of them is that resolved
resolution of large fragments is a
little bit complicated some of the
computer systems do not work well with
those large fragments also capillaries
have attempted to be easily overloaded
and this requires upfront assays late
tuning in order to be made to make sure
that you don't put in too much DNA of
course the cost per sample can also be
significant for a QC pipeline we run
into a systems that typically cost more
than two dollars a sample so these are
all some of the considerations for
what's out there today as far as science
election goes the most commonly used
method for high-throughput pipelines is
to use a debased size-exclusion what
happens there though is that you can
only really do this with any
discriminatory power for fragments
they're less than a thousand base pairs
so it's good option for I consider it
within that range but if you're looking
to recover larger constructs for either
sequencing or cloning purposes this is
not a great option for you also when
you're actually doing size selection for
fragment length distributions that are
less than thousand base pairs if you
have a requirement to recover it tightly
size distribution you're probably going
to experience a high amount high degree
of intrinsic losses now this may not
always be a problem if you have a lot of
material but if the sample is of
questionable quality then you want to be
able to get back as much your material
as possible and the beat that's going to
be a problem the other problem with size
selection fees is that you don't
actually get to see the DNA q so that's
what that's what drives the requirement
for actually conducting an analyte
before size selection and in a lot of
cases after the size selection as well
so in order to address these concerns or
with the existing quality control
workflows and library construction
workflows coastal genomics teamed up we
have talent and robotics support our
Ranger technology to the Nimbus platform
so this is a picture of the system rain
here the system is a nice exchange robot
and it comes with an enclosure that has
built retains to block out any light
that could interfere with imaging with
the imaging process that's conducted
throughout the size selection or
analytic electrophoretically actual
hardware assembly sets compose Ranger
technology the first part of range
technology consists of our
electrophoresis pedestals so the system
can accommodate to electrophoresis
pedestals on the deck and still have
room for about six positions to be used
by the liquid handler our our pedestals
are modular so they can be put on the
deck for a size selection or an
analytics run but they can also be
removed allowing the system to be used
just as a 96 channel liquid handler so
this means that it can be used for
purposes such as pcr setup serial
dilution and such but right here you can
see that the system is mounted with to
electrophoresis pedestals each
electrophoresis pedestal can house up to
four of our agarose sets and right here
we can see that our 12 child-sized
motion cassettes are loaded on post
electrophoresis testa pedestal this
means that if in 96 samples can be sized
selected in a single run however the
system does not require nice examples
anywhere between 196 can be run in a
single run so that makes it a very
flexible and scalable option for a lot
of library construction pipelines the
other component range of technology
consists of gantry arm mounted
assemblies as you can see here through
this slide we do attach a camera to the
gantry arm this is used to capture
images
getta die found DNA found dye molecules
throughout electrophoresis and what we
do to actually cause those dye molecules
to plessis that we actually expose them
to either blue or red light from our
illumination stage the blue light is
actually used to excite the primary dye
molecule which binds to all DNA within
the sample however we also use internal
markers which are exclusively labeled
with a secondary dye molecule and this
is the secondary a molecule is only
excited when exposed to red light this
means that we can effectively identifier
markers every time even though even
though there may be overlap with the
sample that would normally flood out the
signal from the marker but it also means
that for an alleged purposes were
correctly identifying our marker every
time with some compelling electric
research systems that use only a single
die the software can confuse which is
marker and watches sample and that
normally requires the user to go back
into the software to reassign the
appropriate marker that problem is
avoided with this duel diet system that
we've employed here so those badges
range technology as it is integrated
into the nimbus platform and the nimbus
select platform here is basically a high
sex channel liquid handler that is
capable of conducting either size
selection with our size selection
cassettes but it's also capable of
conducting analytics in terms of
generating fragment length distribution
similar to what a capillary
electrophoresis system would do so as
far as the size selection goes the user
sets up the workstation and then the
liquid handler takes over from there
it's going to go ahead and load the
samples in those cassettes it's going to
electric freeze them capture images
generate an electropherogram and then
when the appropriate fraction is ready
to be extracted it will reformat that to
a destination plate and an
electropherogram that is representative
of that size like immature will also be
generated for the user in analytics mode
since we're not conducting size
selection and we're just when your heads
going to get a read on what the fragment
length distribution profile looks like
it's only going to go as far as Jerry
electric paragraph this light here shows
us a little bit about what the user
experiences like for setting up the
actual effect of the instrument 45
selection runs specifically coastal
genomics provides reagent kits which
consists of our agarose gel cassettes as
well as our DNA loading system which
includes the internal markers so the
user will approach the instrument unseal
the cassettes and load them on to the
electrophoresis pedestals along with the
sample plate a pipe for which can act at
the destination plate and our dual dye
marker system as well at that point the
user can interface with the range
technology software suite so this is
something that gives easy to get up and
running with alternatively you can use
our CSV file import system which defines
all of the variables for high-throughput
production facilities so I have a video
here for you and Tracy I'll ask for you
to go ahead and cue that up right now to
show users show everyone what the user
experience is like with the software
user begins by identifying the source
page with either a text name barcode
something that can act as an identifier
for sample tracking purposes throughout
the run after this the user will select
which wells in the source wave actually
how's the samples to be sized selected
nor confirm what kinds of samples are so
here's where you tell whether it's a
next-generation sequencing library or
your life your constructs and then
you'll confirm what the brine is of your
sample hopeful journalist provides
cassettes that have common a prior to 25
or 45 milliliters sample items it's done
the user selects the cassettes that will
be used for processing and confirms the
agarose formulation in those cassettes
once that's complete these are can
initiate to run and return to size
selected samples in to our time window
Thank You Tracy
but once the user has actually initiated
to run through the setup of the software
the instrument then goes ahead and
begins the process of conducting the
size selection this slide here is a
little animation that shows exactly how
it goes about doing that so the first
thing that the nimitz workstation does
is it engages 12 tips on its 96 channel
manifold and it will then move down to
the source plate and operate that sample
from the first row of that source plate
then moves over top of our agarose
cassette right here and the agarose
cassette basically consists of proper
reservoirs of the distal ends of the
cassette and in the middle we have
agarose channels that agarose channel
had has 12 lanes but in each lane
there's a preformed loading well as well
as a preformed extraction well so people
that are used to using the clone wealth
system or will be familiar with this
kind of side selection method here it
prevents the need to actually cut the
agarose gel at all and you just actually
aspirated out in one x tbe buffer system
will put the samples into loading wells
and we have 25 and 45 microliter of
loading wells and then electrophoresis
is initiated again imaging is conducted
in both red light and blue light the red
light allows us to identify the markers
that are in each lane and the blue light
allows us to actually see what the
sample DNA looks like in terms of
fragment length distribution multiple
images are captured throughout the
electropherogram intended to our
software processing algorithm and a
midway point through the run the
software identifies where the target is
in each sample in the cassette so there
will be 12 targets they don't want to be
the same they can vary but the software
decides where those targets are and it's
going to vary the applied voltage on
each channel in order to make sure
that's the arrival of the target
fractions in each channel are are
scheduled so that they come out at the
extraction while at the same time
once that happens the Nimbus elect will
change its tip which is not indicated
here but with clean tip that goes in and
aspirates out target fraction from each
sample and reformat it to the
destination plate that's the principle
behind the size selection ability of the
system for the analytic side of the
system it will simply load the VNA run
out detail and capture images and
produce an electropherogram for the user
at this point there's a movie that shows
the actual system operation and Tracy
I'll ask for you to please cue that up
so the process starts an engagement of
12 tips by the workstation these tips
are going to be used to reform that
sample from the source plate into our 12
channel cassette for size selection
purposes tickets are available from
Hamilton robotics and the reagents are
available from coastal genomics these
tips will be disposed of and 12 new tips
will be used when it comes time to
extract the sample from the extraction
well downstream at this point power
supplied to the cassettes and multiple
images are recorded throughout the
electric credit processing exposure to
red and blue light this is a movie of
the images that are captured by the
camera throughout a run once the target
gets to the extraction well there will
be world clear up get rid of practice
their small and desired target and then
recovery begins notice if there is no
DNA getting past the extraction well
which is indicative of a high intrinsic
recovery yield
thank you crazy
who as far as the metrics for the
assistant performance go right now coach
jomox has available except for size
selection and also except for the four
groups are interested only in analytics
right now we have high resolution
cassettes for that we will also be
releasing low resolution cassettes this
near future here which on a lower per
sample cost but although a lower
resolution as well sighs election
cassettes called two dollars per sample
we find this compares very positively to
other automated side selection systems
that are available on a per sample cost
we believe it also compares very
favorably to manual costs as well for
the size selection itself up to 96
samples can be processed in about a two
hour run time fewer samples of course
can be run and that would take a less
time as well our accuracy is customized
five percent for both the analytics and
the five selection this is a
conservative estimate normally we
actually perform much better than this
and the resolution at one thousand base
pairs is under 25 base pairs so now I'm
going to move into a bit of a discussion
as to what the improvements are when
using a gross gels for size selection
purposes but there are course benefits
beyond just actually being able to see
the DNA and do the size selection as
well I'll go over some of those right
now so when we take a look at what then
it is for size selection high-throughput
groups or even medium throughput groups
today magnetic beads are really taken on
a big role when it comes with it and
magnetic beads are really a great
technology and they work for a lot of
the cases so you know there's there's a
lot to be said for that however there
are cases where being able to conduct a
five sections of gel has its advantages
one of those advantages is recovery over
a tightly defined size selection window
so this graph here depicts a five
selection in green that would be
conducted with magnetic beads where
you're trying to
losing solid entry on a base pairs and
exclude things that are bigger than six
hundred base pairs the blue line
represents what would be recovered using
the Nimbus select with Ranger technology
you'll notice that the big difference
here is the grade with which the roll-on
as we call it climbs on for recovery for
beat based solutions you normally need
to allow for about a hundred to two
hundred base pairs between the apartment
that you want to definitely reject and
to the point where you want maximum
recovery so if you can think about the
area under the graph pertaining as it
pertains to actual recovery of PNA the
vertical lines represents ax horizontal
lines which are indicative of recovery
using the nimitz select represent about
a fifty percent increase in total of
covered DNA so this means that you're
going to have improved sensitivity as
you're going to be able to salvage
samples that maybe aren't the best and
you're also going to be able to be a
little bit more selective in terms of
the fragment length distributions that
you send down for sequencing now a lot
of groups would then say well I could
just widen the size selection window
using magnetic beads and yes that is
true you can do that however if you're
going to do this and there are
considerations for example by widening
out the window you're going to be
covering a lot of short reasons are
shorter than your ideal fragment length
you're also going to be recovering a lot
of adapters as well on the other on the
other hand what you're going for things
are too big you get concatenation large
fragments that can also inhibit the
efficiency of the sequencing reaction
this table here reflects what some of
those results are what some of those
changes can actually do in terms of
results one of the groups that we've
collaborated with used a off gift
protocol here where there was a
prescribed debased clean up for a
production of a library that was to be
run on to my seat system disk cleanup
kit led to a lot of shorter fragments
actually being included in the
in the flow cell genet flow cell
population and this meant that basically
two full-length full read length was not
being taken advantage of they were
having a lot of smaller fragments
getting in there and coming to dominate
the sequencing reaction so limited data
came out the other end when they came to
us we were able to use range of
technology to officially discriminate
between pranks that were too small and
the premise of the correct side we were
able to recover a large fraction of the
large Brett of the fragments that were
larger in size and that led to an
improvement in terms of data yield we
estimate that the actual data to got out
of the run with range of technology
versus magnetic beads was an improvement
that was about sixty percent in terms of
data cube and just to drive this home
about what the improvements are when
you're using gels for a tighter size
selection here this table here shows but
some of the values are in terms of
intrinsic recovery yields when you're
using a beat based system versus the
Nimbus select with Ranger technology
system so for if you're ever having to
do a double-sided size selection where
the target range is going to be about
two hours between 200 and 300 base pairs
if you're using beads for this you can
expect to recover between ten and twenty
percent of the actual material that is
within that window however for fragment
length distributions that are of a
similar size are even smaller on the
range of technology system your yields
are closer to between eighty and ninety
percent so this is great for groups that
are dealing with samples that large
number of samples number of different
collaborators not everybody takes the
same care when it comes to sharing or a
ransom attic digestion time if you're
getting that high recovery yield and you
can just go for that one really large
fragment length distribution each time
and get enough out of that each time to
do actually get a reliable sequencing
run which is not always the case that
you're interested proper yield are low
it's light here also is another
explanation of what the improvements
range technology improvement range
technology can bring to cloning of the
genetic constructs with another
collaborator we actually used the system
to recover a 1.2 kilobase a gene
synthesis construct and the same typical
processes they used of previously that
this was to use magnetic beads to do it
broad size exclusion at that point the
size selected materials from both
processes were her clone transformed
into a bacterial ester and bacterial
vector and grown up on to two separate
plates the client then actually
sequenced the insert from 24 colonies
from each plate and found that 20 22 24
calling process with range technology
came back with the correct size insert
whereas with the traditional magnetic
bead approach because they were
recovering a lot of the smaller
constructs as well weren't effectively
rejecting those only seven of the 24
constructs came back as having the
correct insert so you can think about
this as meaning the number of colleagues
needs a sequence to actually find the
correct construct is far fewer when
you're processing with range of
technology as opposed to using magnetic
be based seismic solution process this
diagram here kind of shows exactly what
the difference is in terms of workflow
the generic magnetic bead processes uses
a beat based size selection and then
actually what will happen is that the
group that's using deet-based by
selection will conduct a construct
analysis and that's normally done just
by running it on a gel if the material
is there then they will go and we'll
just transform that directly but you
know because the because there's so many
smaller truncation products that make it
through the ebay five selection the
number of true positive colonies are
going to be far fewer there than they
are when you're using Ranger technology
so much so that we estimate that we're
saving roughly half the number of
sequencing reactions
would be required in order to have a
ninety-five percent chance to identify a
true positive so to sum up here the
nimbus select with range technology is
definitely a high-capacity low-cost
solution for both 5 selection and
analytics so if you're currently running
gels precise selection or if you're
using computer electrophoresis systems
this is a good option to think about
because it's not only well is that
reduce the operating costs it's also
going to improve the actual results that
you're getting downstream the other
consideration here is that this solution
is one that is ported on to a Nimbus 96
channel instrument and as such it can be
used as a nice legs channel to good
handler as well all the hardware
assemblies are modular and can be taken
off of the deck Noren to allow it to
serve the purpose of a general liquid
handler so anyone that's in the market
for either a size selection system or
kapil electrophoresis system or liquid
handler should consider the Nimbus
select as it can conduct all of these
operations in employment workstation
that's my presentation today I want to
thank everyone for attending and I'd be
happy to answer any questions that you
would like to submit
again I'd like to thank everyone for
joining us for this conference call and
presentation and is there any questions
please don't hesitate to reach out to
your local Hamilton robotics rep or you
can contact us by checking out gossage
Jones website at WWE hosted genomics com
thank you